it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you're listening to inside of
you with Michael Rosenbaum Wow it is
2020 wasn't that a TV show ryeom yeah
with Barbara Walters Barbara what Baba
Baba Baba that on center net live
remember uh sherry she did it this year
yeah Anderson Cooper losing his mind
he's in the clip no oh it's hilarious
really yeah Anderson Cooper's just
losing it
he loves it yeah it was the best thing
so was a little tipsy
I think so you had to be tipsy singers
you know
so look guys this is awesome we're back
for another season of inside of you and
I want to thank you this is this is
awesome it's been a long year of like
abandonment issues and guests with great
stories in tragedy a lot of laughs and
I'm just really grateful I'm grateful to
be back to to be doing the show I love
doing it I talked to you about this a
lot we wanted to do something special
this year and I talked to Brice and Ryan
who's here with me first of all Ryan I
want to give a shout out Ryan how do you
pronounce your last name
hey is yeah you can't say tell us no
tell us more it's taya's there's a first
baseman who plays for the Toronto Blue
Jays who goes by rowdy to lez rowdy to
lose and it's it dig it rolls but it's
I've just been told that it's trans day
as my whole life and that's Ryan tears
god dammit
hey man yeah live with it you know Rob
Hollis took off we had an agreement and
he was just you know he was doing making
a lot of money he's got a family and he
had to do what he had to do and we're
still buddies and I wish him the best
and so he left and we had started this
in the beginning and I was sort of like
a bit out of a law you know at a loss
and like I'm a man and you get all these
things feelings inside you I
you know I thought he's leaving even
though it's mutual but he's leaving and
my shows not as successful as Dax is and
comparing yourself and that's when you
go down this wormhole of negativity and
it just doesn't nobody any good
especially yourself and I learned a lot
of that you know you fast forward to me
going to a well in the center last year
and taking care of my [ __ ] I think
things just got they caught up with me
and I had to handle them I think you
either don't handle them and where you
handle them in whatever way you can and
getting help and I did that well it
wasn't it wasn't because Rob left by the
way it was it was the culmination of
things surgeries botched surgeries
don't use this surgeon his name it I'm
just gonna I'm not gonna tell you that
one I don't know if I want to go there
yeah I don't go there right now but um
you know Ryan came on board and we were
just having art night something I
learned at the Wellness Center and I was
like Ryan's like you know III am I right
could you can you engineer sure I can
write and I it turns out I can you you
did you did a fantastic job
another thing that's coming up by the
way so but first of all I'm grateful for
you Ryan and I'm grateful tears that
you're here thanks Rosen but I am it's
really nice it's I started out as an
episode let's see what happens and now
we're doing them you know the top 13
clips that we're gonna show or what
sorry that we're going to to have you
listen to are not necessarily the best
guests or the best they're just great
moments that we hear it inside of you
myself and Bryce we looked through and
you know we thought these were great
moments a nice moment and relevant to
the show they they sort of just depict
the show in if you put them all together
it's kind of what the show is about it's
you know anyway you'll hear these in a
moment these top 13 not top ten last
it's the top 13 moments but remember
these aren't necessarily the best guest
although they are great guests what's
great is what we've decided here and
inside of you to start doing video now
you're thinking if you're listening to
this you're like wait a minute what and
a lot of people have asked and we
thought it was a good idea and so we're
gonna do video now we're gonna
transition from the audio to the video
so that's gonna take a little time we've
have some guests that we did audio some
great guests coming up
so you got to listen to them we've got
stephen amell great guest and we're
gonna start doing the video so i'm doing
the whole video set up I stole some of
those guys at Bobby Lee's podcast and
they're gonna help me set a nice nice
little video stuff here and my friend
Ryan here happens to do a lot of other
things so he's gonna help me out with a
video it's been a great year also I
joined patreon
do you guys know patreon holy [ __ ] Ryan
this is the coolest thing ever and I'm
lost because for five years people been
doing this but if you love something if
you love a podcast you could join
patreon and you could subscribe sounds
like now who wants to pay money well
it's amazing how people really loyal
listeners want to support the podcast
support me paying you and paying other
people and making the show better and
doing the video and and also it just
feels like a family you know I thought
oh I would just do it I'm required to do
but I've already like had it text people
on it and say hey thanks for this I
become it becomes like it patreon to me
is more like a friend in a way I mean
you have to have your space I'm really
grateful to all the patreon so
subscribed there's tiers on there if you
want to be a patreon member there's so
many cool things depending on the tier
you're in but you get extra footage
extra me rambling that just will be seen
on patreon that you won't see here we
have a thing called shit-talking which
we talked to guess I talked to guests
and I asked some questions that some of
the patreon asked they want to know it's
all patreon questions and I will ask
each guest the questions I mean at least
the 10 and I choose each week and
there's so much more the [ __ ] talking
with Rosenbaum we've got two Q&A
sessions with me alone that only my
patrons will get to see so it's really
cool so check it out join me join me and
we'll have a lot of fun we always have
fun anyway and I just really appreciate
the support
what else so Tom Welling and I have a
new wine out Ryan we did wine last year
for knocking point at Stephen amell's
wine and they asked us I guess we sold
out last year we were the biggest
grossing wine Wow so they want to do it
again so this year there's a Mick
a little spin I get to be the peer it's
called pure evil wine
I was the evil last time tom was pure
because you know mm-hmm and now I'm the
pure and he's the evil it's pretty cool
we love it we love wine if you like wine
and you want to use my what kind of wine
is it you know it's like Tom's is a red
and I'm the white I'm always the white
because I like white wine so you'll just
have to see go - knocking point calm
type in the code pure and take an
additional 10% off so all you have to do
is go to knocking point wines calm slash
taste makers - Club and get some pure
evil wine with me and Tom willing also
I'll be in Portland at the end of
January here if you want to come see me
and Welling at a con and that would be a
lot of fun we do these things called
Smallville Knights I don't know if you
know it but um if you go to a con Tom
and I improvise we read old Smallville
scripts I might wear a bald cap I don't
know Tom whereas a flannel perhaps we
have special guests occasionally it's a
lot of fun I'd like to say a little
shout out we're talking about the
patreon I'd like to give a little shout
out in the beginning and the outro of
the show and the intro I'd like to shout
out to the top tier patrons that's
Angelina gee it's almost Angelina Joji
Lena I'm not following
no I'm not either Angela G Bobby D on K
Jerry W Jill E
Kevin R Lauren G Lea or Lee s Robert B
Taylor BN yukiko yeah I like that name
Yukiko or you Keiko I think it's you
Kiko what do you think I think you Kiko
sounds right I think so but anyway
listeners I want to thank you
20:19 was a learning curve for me and
growing and let's get into the top 13
we've got a fantastic year coming at you
many great guests I'm digging deep I'm
pulling them out of the shadows I think
you're gonna be really excited with all
this I I know it this is gonna be a
bigger year than last year
ladies and gentlemen this is the inside
of you top 13 moments of 2019 that's
right the top 13 moments you know Ryan
this guest I don't know if you were here
for this Richard Marx I was not here
which one mark she weren't here but
Richard and I have a bit of a
relationship not not sexually i had
tweeted something and they tweeted back
he says hey Smallville was a big thing
for my family and I we used to watch
Smallville every week and I'm like wow
great can I have a song for my movie
directing back in the day she's like
yeah and you want to be in it
and we started this whole friendship and
we went to see Lionel Richie together
and we'd go out because he was single at
the time and he was looking for love but
he was kind enough to come in here and
not only that this is what I want I want
to strive to be he wasn't nervous about
playing music on a podcast I was like do
you want me to add in a fact door I
guess no you want me to add a little
reverb no what do you need I don't need
anything I need a mic and he said that
right before we went on the air and he
gave a killer live performance of a song
that I love so let's go to Richard Marx
live on the top 13 moments of 2019 what
do you want to play nice the song from
your oh yes can I get in sure it like a
DJ right now off the coast 96 WSTO we've
got Richard and one you see hey not
Richard so you you start strumming a
little so they could hear the beginning
whoa okay yeah yeah I mean but yeah so
it's yeah you got a time it just so
though right right right right
94.7 w KD q off the coast Richard Marx
now with us an oldie but a goodie
endless summer nights from the movie
back in the day that didn't make a red
cent
[Music]
morning all in one step so you're gone
now you looking back at me said you
finally then we can be back before you
[Music]
say give him a left for one night having
you here to home a title clean baby the
I can
[Music]
your time is only haryana to be singing
by
No
[Music]
as only is so much I can't say so please
don't run away from what we have to bear
so only you and me tonight so let's stay
lost and fly she please surrender
[Music]
you
me time is on me and [ __ ]
[Music]
losing my son
yeah
[Music]
94.7 richard marx off the coast wow if
you if you hadn't heard that song you're
probably have that under plymouth you
know what 2019 brought a lot of fun a
lot of making fun of me which is always
good picking on me
this next guest I think you know him
this is number 12 in the top 13 list of
2019 he's been on the podcast before
this is I believe his second appearance
and we go to cons together we have a lot
of fun together he just had a kid we do
wine together we made a wine we've we've
had a friendship that's lasted more than
just a hit TV show so this is Tom
Welling
I guess roasting me about potential new
lex luthor's in the future and Rob who
was was on here he's these poke and fun
- so here's number 12 on the top 13 this
is Tom Welling yeah see what kind of fan
base you having it's an unfortunately or
fortunately I don't know but like your
Instagram followers this how many people
does he have is I am to be I know
there's a big producer actor director
the only cast people based on their IMDB
number if you're not top 10 you're not
in cast in you yeah it's so [ __ ] it's at
its advertising outreach I'm not gonna
say the person because I really like the
person it's just what he does business
if he ever got out I would be he would
never [ __ ] cast me in any please
Oliver's any levar difference maybe
after this vodcast them Michael what are
you doing this weekend I see the you
five more followers that want to hire
you like what's the number that you have
to be to get his attention a million
five hundred oh no I only have a couple
hundred thousand followers I think I
mean I mean it's not compared to these
the Beavers not Tom Welling beavers got
a hundred million Tom you go at four
hundred fifty thousand followers well
that's not but not enough for this guy
no but those youtubers have 20 million
that's
I'm talking numbers on IMDB Pro like the
your number your star meter but star
meters bigger your number lat yeah if
you're like number 20 Z
how did doesn't that work that just
means that you're popular like right now
maybe if you hire somebody to do a movie
right now it doesn't come out for you
that person might not be popular here
from now I don't know it seems like the
same people are always up there like you
know the you know the capper is probably
top 15 all the time well but he's
DiCaprio yeah yeah and he deserves that
good and everything well Gina happens
better DiCaprio's um I think he's
working on something where he's gonna
play Lex Luthor DiCaprio is in you [ __ ]
I was like oh my god really wait what
you know it's funny as you don't care DK
I just a text James gonna go dude I'm
not asking you for anything but you're
doing Suicide Squad if I'm not playing
Lex Luthor that would be dope but he
just goes he said you didn't even if
it's just sit tight just [ __ ] off I have
a feeling that means that there's
probably not gonna be a Lex Luthor
Monsieur so it's gone no Leonardo
DiCaprio got casted there you go first
of all right for Suicide Squad it's
right there oh it's on the internet
where to go there's a picture of it let
me see it you're a [ __ ] life oh yeah
you know DiCaprio Lex Luthor I mean it's
on the internet it must be true yeah
isn't that doesn't that piss you off the
other like oh he was a great Lex Luthor
or he was a great Clark Kent so they
were on TV so they can't be great in
film I don't understand that either it's
not stupid it's just
especially when the fans are like don't
are you listening to fans every once in
a while just every once in a while
listen to them do you think it would
hurt DC if they cast me right who played
it for 7 or 10 or whatever you want to
say years I'm just not blowing smoke but
they've done these polls of the better
Lex Luthor and if we want to I'm just
saying do you think it would hurt DC do
you think they'd go from a hundred
million weekend oh it's Rosenbaum
instead of some so you know what it's
gonna be five million do you think that
it's all of a sudden gonna ruin the
franchise for a Lex Luthor that has
worked to them plate am I upset about
that sleazy please comment and subscribe
let's start a poll I don't know I just I
don't think you want to see this while
it what is it I don't think you're the
15 best actors who should have played
better Luthor Joaquin Phoenix Michael
Fassbender Bryan Cranston late great
Bradley Cooper Michael C Hall but they
didn't play it so we don't know it's a
moot point they didn't play it for seven
years this one number 11 on the top 13
moments of 2019 this guy became a friend
we ended up doing a podcast call in love
with Michael Rosenbaum and Chris
Sullivan and he really taught me about
being grateful thank you Chris Sullivan
I love you and if you guys want you
could subscribe and listen to in love
with Michael Rosen my man Chris Sullivan
it would hurt you much good it is
frequently mislabeled as depression but
it's this feeling of worthlessness and
that the world is a terrible place that
eats away at me alright a lot at a lot
of people but it's I believe that all of
these years when I thought oh maybe I'm
depressed maybe I need this maybe need
this is this idea of it's just negative
self-talk it's negative self thinking
it's low self-esteem it's it's a it's a
lot of things rolled up into one but it
seems to be like it was too complicated
an idea there was like add laziness
we'll just call it laziness will call it
sloth and that type of thinking is
something that you have to actively
fight against because we all have it
inside us that you look around and and
everything that's happening in the world
if you look around long enough and
you're not depressed by what you see I
don't know anyone who especially now is
is is able to kind of process everything
that's happening in the world with
out ending up a little down acedia
acedia tell me about how you how you
deal with it how every day it sounds to
me like it's part of like cognitive
behavioral theory out there yeah you
know thinking of thinking positively
changing the way you think right yeah
therapy it's it's a living in conscious
gratitude writing it down sharing it
with others where you write this down
seriously I'm not gonna listen to this
because I'm doing it right now
well write that down cuz I want to do
that I I'm writing down riding down
positive things like I am grateful I
have a new puppy Blanche you know what
we could do everyday and I do it with a
couple of my friends we have a cup of my
wife and I have different text threads
going we today I am grateful for dot dot
dot three things you and I could do that
and we can do it every day and doesn't
have to be a big conversation it could
be three things that we just send to
each other and when when it's written
down and when it's shared with someone
else it becomes this tangible thing in
our lives that we can use throughout the
day to remember to kind of get outside
of ourselves number ten on the top
thirteen last up 2019 Julie Benz this is
cool because Julie she she like goes
into my DM not because she's hitting on
me she's married but she'll slide in and
be like dude you're episode with
so-and-so was so amazing it really
touched me she listens to them and when
actors your peers or listening to the
podcast folks it makes me feel like I'm
doing something right and I'm just
honored by it and her talking about her
panic attack right after getting killed
off and Dexter just listened probably
like ten years ago I just had to accept
what it meant to be an actor in order to
love the good of our jobs when it's good
and all the goodness that goes with it
you also have to accept the bad parts
that go with it you can accept the bad
parts you have to you can't you can't
just have the good without the bad
what's the worst thing that happened you
as an actress the worst thing I mean of
rejection or whatever I mean I mean
getting killed off Dexter was pretty bad
I had no idea I had no idea that was
coming when did they tell you
and
three days before who called you
they called me in on my day off to do
some ADR and then they called me to the
producers room and I knew walking from
the ADR stage to the producers room when
you get called to the producers you're
being killed off the show I mean it's
just you just yeah I suffer from panic
attacks and I started having a panic
attack and I called my manager at the
time and I said oh my god I think
they're killing me off and he this is
what he said he's like all right kid
okay because he he knows I suffer from
panic attacks and he's like just get in
now as fast as you can just say thank
you and get out and I was like okay and
then I called my husband who was my
boyfriend at that time and I said and
he's not in the business and I said oh
my god I'm walking to the producers
office I think I'm being killed off the
show and he's like maybe they're giving
you a raise which like really broke my
heart because I was like no you gotta
fight for the raise and then he said the
same thing and he said just get in and
out as fast as you can and get home and
I'll meet you at home so I tried to get
it out as fast as I could like I walked
in the room and I said you know I know
what this is about
I wanted people it was three the three
executive producers all men know one
woman yeah and I said thank you so much
for a great four years I've appreciated
everything I did before the world before
there's no word I said I'm smart enough
to know what's going on so thank you for
great four years let's talk tomorrow I
mean because I'm feeling the panic
attack they wanted to you know to have a
conversation and so then I had to sit
down and let me release at this stage
because to make matters worse I worked
out a gym right by the studio and so I
was I had worked out that morning and it
was really hot like hot like today hot
so I was only in a sports bra and a pair
of like leggings and I went to do a TR
you hired you I went to do a TR that way
so all I could think about was what was
that movie where the guy gets broken up
with while he's naked
is it forgetting forgetting sarah
marshall forgetting sarah marshall
that's all I could think about was like
I don't have a shirt on and I'm losing
my job and I'm like sitting there like
trying to think I felt so vulnerable but
they wanted to discuss it they wanted to
tell me the reasons why and and in I you
know they needed to do that for their
own their own clarity I guess their own
therapy because everybody was upset
about it but you cry in the room I did
which I didn't want to UM did they hug
you they did but I was sweaty and smell
the clothes on basically were you
balling I was I was really upset you
loved the show I loved it
oh it was such a great family and then
here you are being told like okay well
we're still gonna like get together as a
family but so it was really hard how
long did it take you to recover from
that
it took a while it took awhile I am I
remember therapy for that I did I did
did they pay for no I should have I
should I remember I met um Elizabeth
Mitchell right after I was doing I got a
I was doing some little indie film and I
was working with her and the episode had
an aired yet so nobody really knew and I
was talking to her on set one day and I
I told her about it and you know she had
been killed off of lost and it was a
very similar situation where like they
didn't tell you they don't you know
didn't tell the actor until the last
minute they did tell her to last minute
or whatever and I was like you know they
want me to do press for the show and do
interviews after it airs like how do I
handle that and she's like just be
honest
what does what I did was like yeah I got
killed off the show it's the hooked for
me like I was upset
you know she's and that's just the only
way I know how to deal with that so it
was hard and my therapist was really
great because you know when I went to
see him and I was crying and I was like
everybody know I felt like I got fired
that's what it feels I could get fired
he he said to me he's like listen when
I'm watching a really great show and and
a character gets killed off I'm not
thinking oh my god that actor just got
fired I'm thinking well this is great
storytelling
[Music]
number nine is a guy that you know
afterwards he's like look I don't I
don't really talk about this stuff I
don't know it was a weird was it you
know you just he's so I another
authentic guy I think a lot of these
guests I get on the show are just
authentic and I think maybe it's just my
soft-spoken mnestheus why are you
talking like that oh no Matt no no
Bobcat Goldthwait Goldthwait gold plate
number nine in the top 13 moments of
here's Bobcat lately that's my thing
I've been really connecting with old
friends on purpose why uh just because
you just talk a lot of [ __ ] hey let's
get together boy we had fun and now I
actually do it like I just I buy ticket
I fly across the country let's not take
a lot of your time it doesn't matter I'm
cuz it's meaningful and it's also just
like oh do you remember that day you you
worked on that script all day or do you
remember that time you surprised Tony on
his 65th birthday yeah which which am I
gonna remember you know what's the
project you're most proud of you've
worked on that you're like I think it's
like call me lucky and I think World's
Greatest Dad the movie I did with Robin
like those movies I like them all for
different reasons but those are the two
where I felt they had the most fun no it
was the two where I think I kinda came
closest to what I was trying to do do
you get over [ __ ] quickly no I mean
that's why like I said to my friend who
just this other fellow who I had worked
with and I did know and it's a really
good guy Kevin Burnett he passed away
but I went to his two closest friends
Josh and Jermaine and I was like you
know when this happens I you kind of
feel like you're not allowed to live
your life because you're forgetting this
person because these guys were so close
to him like if I laugh I feel like I'm
betraying Robin if I continue my life I
feel like I'm betraying him I'm not he
would want me to of course and it's hard
it's easier if it's not someone who
takes their own life but when someone
dies it's an arm and that's missing and
that and it is in a way but you do you
will experience joy again that's that's
I think that comes from experience and
that comes from just living and hitting
rock bottom and so many times you know
so many times that you're like going I
mean because what's the alternative when
someone dies you think well I'm gonna do
this you know we're gonna have Memorial
and that'll help and it won't or it does
for some some ways but it doesn't or
we're gonna I'm gonna go on a trip and
go to a beach and that doesn't do it
it's I think time is the thing you know
do you do you ugly cry do you go home by
yourself and cry like no one's ever seen
if some person crying yeah you know it's
funny I well up a commercial but then I
those big blowout cries it's been a long
time what's the last time he had one of
those I think his when Rob passed away
but it was it was weird cuz it didn't
come at all when people expected it what
about success I was on a plane wait you
weren't a plane when you found out you
had no no no I'd found out and
everything but the big ugly cry came
when I was on a point Robin had the
worst taste in music
he was like all apologies to anybody I
probably love it I bet it's like cheesy
music no but it's just like just
anything like he didn't really he wasn't
for some reason that wasn't something
was passionate strange
so in World's Greatest Dad the song
under pressure is used in a couple ways
as she's comedic Lee and then she's at
the end of the film and he loved it he's
like I'm gonna I'm gonna make that my
song like he wanted that song when
people play when he walked onto a
talk-show
he wanted that pressure he wanted that
but no way people are gonna play rock
and Robin or you know [ __ ] from
Aladdin or something so and I just put
on my headset and and that song came on
and then I just lost my mind I just
thought a planet just like what people
know someone next to you know I don't
know what they were making I just buried
my face in the
no and just laught and sob down number
eight this is a woman who I've always
been in love with I do this charity
echoes of hope for foster youth and I
host it and I've had to I always see her
in the crowd she's part of it and I
would introduce her or I'd say some
funny things and I'd sort of be you know
I had a crush and one time she gave me
kiss on the lips and we're just were
buddies you know I'm obviously you know
not her kind of guy I wear sweatpants
but she's a real down-to-earth girl but
what I loved about this podcast this
moment are these moments is that I
really felt bad because when she's
talking about working with Bill Murray
and I'm like did he hug you
did he just listen to what she says this
is really profound Andie MacDowell have
you ever had sex with Bill Murray no I
did not I wasn't even sure Biff liked me
to tell you the truth I was doing
everything I could what you he was
attracted to you and into it did you
find him so talented and funny that you
might have considered it were you single
at the time no I wasn't interested in
heaven you've never cheated you're not
that girl I'm not gonna say whether I
was purely pure I'm not gonna get into
that but I can tell you I didn't sleep
with Bill Murray does it build Murray
make you laugh all the time
was he improvising a lot or was it
improvised a lot Bill's bill is moody
he's a moody person and so it depending
on his mood whether he was making me
laugh or not he was he could be he can
be intimidating
biggest one of the biggest community
is's of all time he is a genius I will
give him gonna make did he make you ever
was he the same person off camera as he
was on camera was this weird as he can
be he's a very strange person I meant
when you're doing your lines does he
give you what what'd you give him when I
was working with him he's all you have
to do is be present and pay attention
and and be involved in the scene because
he's so good and they're always
different
so it's the best acting you can do
because it's not formulated you know I
some people just over prepare and it's
just like bad acting I'm sorry
yeah and it was it was never like that
it was always fresh and authentic and
sort of in the moment very sponsor was
very spot he's very extremely
spontaneous and you just had to listen
and react so it's that old Meisner thing
which I wasn't even like a huge Meisner
student but it's pretty simple
technology listen and pay attention and
be present did Bill Murray ever look at
you and say you were really great in the
movie you were really really shy I was
it was a joy to work I loved working
with you know
I would be floored he never said Andy no
great take no Andy you look stunning
today I don't think so you worked within
three months I don't have any memories
of that I was intimidated by him but
always kind I kind of felt like that's
how to deal with him was he coming back
sometimes was he always gonna give me a
big fat trouble I don't think he wants
to work with me again he either I don't
get that from I don't think that's gonna
Groundhog Day - nope it's not I do think
he's a genius and we've seen him since
then and it's the same kind of feeling
when I see him I adore him I would do
anything if he would hug me that would
mean so much to me but it's not gonna
isn't that something how that's all you
wanted really is if he just gave you one
hug I think you know that would it be
he's just the kind of person that you
know for me I felt like I was constantly
I might cry this is terrible just oh
just constantly trying to please him
like everything I did like every moment
of every second I was around him it was
to try to keep him happy and to please
him
inside of you is brought to you by Sun
basket juice cleanse ryeom intermittent
fasting carb cycling struggle to see
long-lasting results from any of these
what if instead you tried eating real
food dude
no matter your lifestyle son basket
caters to your kind of healthy with
delicious recipes for all kinds of
dietary preferences including paleo
gluten-free Mediterranean vegetarian or
more I just got three bags of
gluten-free
everything I needed to make a delicious
meal I like things when they're brought
to my house with everything
pre-portioned that's what I need ready
to prep and cook that's it
you don't need to go I mean a three
tenths of a spoon of cat paprika
what's a call paprika mmm-hmm that's a
new thing you can enjoy a dinner full of
organic produce and clean ingredients in
as little as 15 minutes no matter how
much experience you have in the kitchen
and that's exactly I took a nutrition
class and I didn't do well but it
doesn't matter cuz this stuff's easy
each week son basket offers at least
fourteen recipes to choose from so you
can try mouth-watering dishes such as
salmon burgers with lemon dill mayo
gingered steak stir-fried with broccoli
Mediterranean garlic shrimp Spanish rice
I love this stuff they brought
everything to me it tasted fresh and
delicious I was inspired I felt like I
was accomplishing something and it
didn't take me three hours to make a
meal it was quick and when they say you
are what you eat Ryan it's not a joke
man
right now son basket is offering $35 off
your order when you go right now to son
basket dot-com slash inside and enter
promo code inside at checkout at son
promo code inside a check out for $35
off your order
son basket dot-com slash inside an enter
promo code inside
number seven uh you know again this is
out of order but this guy I mean I gotta
tell you he got me in the Wellness
Center he told me about it he told me
about his life he opened up we cried
about our moms the first time he was on
the second time I learned even more
he's uh he's gonna come back he wants to
interview me on the show also worth
talking about maybe doing live podcast
not just Zach and I myself inside of you
taking it on the road do you think
people would come and watch yeah sure
I've been to others and it's like oh
there's hundreds of people here I mean I
think absolutely I think it'd be
embarrassing if I showed up in like
there's eight people there but I guess
what do you do right you're like hey
thanks for coming yeah you do it anyway
you do it anyway course you gotta stop
worrying about other people or you know
what's the word well you you know it's
like validation like oh oh 200 people
came so that means you're good or worthy
[ __ ] that man how about I love the
podcast people love the podcast if they
show up they show up and what if one of
those eight people is the Dalai Lama I
mean that would be pretty cool man that
could happen
maybe they come on stage yeah keep come
on stage yeah why not alright this guest
number seven again in no particular
order number seven of the top 13 moments
of 2019 Zachary Levi I had this
conversation with Dax Dax Shepard yeah
yeah on a plane where it started to get
heated or he was talking about mental
illness and I was like agreeing but I
was also saying sexual molestation a Mel
station molest Jeanette molesting Jesus
I can't speak but you know as a kid
there was some things that happen to me
that like I dodged some bullets and I
still had I still like I remember the
feeling I had as a child so scared so
nervous what's gonna happen and I wasn't
even molested but it was close like I
almost like I escaped and I could tell
you that story on them and I will say
that now when I hear these stories I can
relate to that scared little boy or girl
that is just that's going through that
in a small way where I'm like oh look
I was molested when I was a kid by
another kid and the ramifications of
that have followed me throughout my
entire life literally introducing me to
sex at a time
we shouldn't have been interested you
shouldn't be how old were you about five
I think four or five something like that
it's amazing you just move back for most
people can't remember what they do when
they're five but you that do that vivid
and vivid memories starting around
around three or four I mean I don't
remember all of it but I mean I have
very vivid tangible memories and also
you know I of course I have to always
assume that there could be some
romanticizing in my own brain you know
like do you really remember moments
exactly the way even as an adult do you
remember a moment exactly how it went
down or do you have there there you know
there's all kinds of studies on this
kind you know you remember somebody
wearing a black suit when they were
wearing a blue suit or whatever I don't
know
I'm not professing I know everything
that happened to me exactly when I was a
child
but I know what happened to me it's so
crazy you said that because I've never
really talked about this but the same
thing happened to me there's another kid
oh so they did and I never have talked
about it but now that you talked about
it I feel like I'm [ __ ] this is the
first time we talked about it I think
this might be the first time that I've
talked about this but like on this but
you know I talked to my therapist about
I go oh so you've talked to his
therapist yeah oh yeah and I said as
this affected me and he looked at me and
said no you didn't affect you because
the person was so it was young you were
both young it's hard to explain cuz you
looked at me like wait wait what are you
saying what I'm saying was they weren't
old enough to think they were a teenager
I was young we were similar in age she
was you know but I felt like I was like
but this was still wrong this was still
something that I I blocked out for many
many years and then I told him about it
and I really wanted him to tell me yeah
you're [ __ ] up because of this and he
said you're not it didn't affect you
well we will
but this but that's a that's a big
statement well it's a big saving but
it's also a big spectrum like you might
you might not you might not be [ __ ] up
by it but I I'm sorry I don't agree that
you weren't affected every single thing
that happens in our day affects us what
I'm saying is how old was the person
that you know I mean I think that that
kid was like two years older so the
seven and a five year old so something
like I think what my explanation it was
more of like well yeah yeah I didn't
want to explore yeah yeah but that's the
thing though is that I think that this
kid I mean I I think that his like
looking back on it with the with the now
the the mind that I have in the heart
that I have in the understanding that I
found on my life
clearly that kid was being molested by
somebody in his life the way that all of
that went down and the way that how it
affected me then even after that like
yes sure young ages kids are exploring
and doing things and that's totally
understandable I'm not it wasn't I don't
feel like it was an adult you know being
a predator on me right and I and I never
even judged the kitty but but my mom you
freaked out you nobody knew about this
oh yeah you know about this yeah so
there was all kinds of effects I mean
even if nobody knew about it it still
would have an effect on and when I say I
blocked it out
I just didn't think anything was like I
was so young that I didn't think
anything was wrong with it so all of a
sudden I'm like thirty one day I just go
hey that happened yeah wait a minute
that's that that happened Wow
why do I remember that now it was the
craziest [ __ ] thing I mean and do you
think you were affected or do you that I
definitely was affected I mean that
compounded by all of the other issues
that I was going through and held and
carried throughout my childhood and
having a psychologically abusive mom
because she was psychologically abused
in all of the ways that that manifested
in
my life as a kid and with my sisters and
my stepdad who was also an abuse he I
guaranteed he was abused when he was
growing up and then he became an abusive
person when he was older and I wouldn't
change any of it now at all because now
I'm on the other side of it and can look
back on it and actually appreciate the
fact that it brought me to being healthy
or in a journey of being I'm not saying
I'm completely you know absolved and
this is all good and I'm like you know
whatever thinking level nine or what
happened I'm just saying I've now gotten
to the other side of what that darkness
that wanted to kill me was doing and I
was able to pierce through and love of
friends and family and the tools that I
learned in all that therapy to get
through that darkness and then from the
other side of the darkness to be able to
look back and go oh yeah [ __ ] yeah all
that happened and all of it led me to
here and I'm grateful for all of that
stuff that led me to here because now on
this side I get to talk about all that
[Music]
number six is probably Ryan taya's my
engineers favorite I've known this guy a
long time I remember anybody was doing
the state I was like you're so funny and
little that I know I mean he made very
little money on that show was a big
group of people on the state and then
they would do these you know three lines
here funny guy and a scene fighting
three bangers you know three bangers are
no they're the trailer when you get a
trailer either get a big trailer because
you're the lead or you get a double
banger because there's you know two
rooms in a trailer because you know
you're maybe a second lead or then a
triple bang or a three banger is you're
probably you could be an extra I think
he was on like a ten banger with all the
members of the spare was just like his
room was the size of cuz I've had those
rooms where it's honest so you could go
in there I'm not sure if there was even
a urine on there I think you have to go
to the men's room
but anyway I mean he fought and he
fought and you know his I think what we
got from this podcast you tell me what
you got he talks about entitle me talks
about how you can't expect anything
given to you in life and boy is that
true is there anything you want to
change about yourself Ryan things all
right being so open you know I mean
that's have you as a guest I'm not a
guest I know
I'm just getting paid to be here you
mean open up is that all you are but I
mean you know you get you get sad right
you could get sad no do ya you cry alone
or you cryin front of people uh no I've
card in front of I mean I think we just
talked about this before I've kind of
heard of my girlfriend Amanda oh it's
mostly with movie stuff right I know
that but I'm talking about like dad no I
mean it just it's just like a y-you know
I get anxious all the time I'm like an
anxious I'm an anxious person do you
meditate I don't because I don't think
I'd have the patience so you know what
that's what everybody thinks and dude I
meditated for 20 minutes and if I told
you two minutes I had it my mind was
clear it's worth it just to maybe get
two minutes I'm telling you you just
keep doing it you think my mind doesn't
keep effing going it does so Joe lo
Truglio number six of the top 13 moments
of 2019 this is a very interesting part
of the conversation we're segwaying into
now because what you're talking about is
accepting when your time is right I had
a long time accepting when my time was
going to be many actors go through that
Mark Kevin Jackson just did a podcast
with Brooklyn nine-nine and I was
talking about Brooklyn nine-nine in that
I almost didn't go in for Brooklyn
nine-nine
I almost didn't get Brooklyn nine-nine
because I'd gone and I put myself on
tape for Alison Jones then they wanted
me to come back in for a callback or a
session at that point I was doing a very
kind of dark time in my career in my
head about my career like you know what
I've done super bad I've done all these
like little movies like enough is enough
like everyone knows what I can do like
cast me or don't cast me but like I'm
tired of it I was really the ego was all
overwhelming swallowing me up and so I
almost didn't go and if I didn't go I
wouldn't have down the show clearly more
importantly the lesson learned is that
no one owes you anything and if you're
doing a job because you're expecting to
get another job you got to find what you
like about it I know that's you hear it
all the time you finally join what you
do but the older to get you realize
that's really the truth because
it put me in such a mood of I know this
and people know what I can do and just
give it to me give it to me
entitlement that it really starts to
weigh you down and it starts to
infiltrate you in in in negative ways
and you don't enjoy where you're around
I remember Ken Marino it's why it's such
a great guy his wife Erica Yama wrote
this thing really funny digital series
called burning love that Ken was in of
so many funny people were in that and I
was shooting that and I was just in a
terrible mood and like can either bring
me insight like while we're shooting you
know I didn't know disruption during the
set but between takes I was just like
not the greatest of moods and he said
what's up man he's like man I can't I
love you I love this this is so funny
like I just gonna be doing this like web
shows like it was really narrow-minded
ungrateful type of stuff and he heard me
as a friend and he related and Here I am
talking to someone that also hadn't got
his big but Ken's amazing it's and all
this stuff but also hadn't gotten his
break and you've realized you just end
up sounding like a complete [ __ ]
because you can't see your path you
can't see when is your time and it took
me a while and if I if I had kept in
that kind of mode well then I don't get
Brooklyn nine-nine and now Brooklyn
nine-nine has given me a gift that is
above and beyond I mean I have a new
family I've gone through life changes
several of us have gotten married
several of us have gotten have had kids
including myself if I had like now [ __ ]
it I'm not going in that is not open to
me anymore that's not here and that's a
very humbling place to be when you're
like now I'm getting it this struggle is
real even after you think you've made
the big time not the big time but like
super bad it is super bad I'm like that
movie was huge I'm like oh well here we
go
the only a matter of time now start
getting the calls here they come they
don't come you know you still have to go
in yourself to do all that stuff so you
just have to keep it in check because no
one owes you anything no one's gonna
give you the money for the movie
no one's gonna write the script for you
no one's going to like create the ideal
part for you you find it you get it or
just
or if you don't know how to get it
follow the things that are coming at you
that are opening up to you and maybe
that will lead you there this number
five was pretty emotional I couldn't
believe that he actually teared up on
the show that makes me feel like they're
comfortable they're comfortable enough
to talk about their stuff in front of me
and I truly appreciate it I think this
is a guy who loves his family loves his
fans loves Fame which i think is okay
when you're in a healthy place you can
love fame and do great things because of
fame fame can give you the opportunity
to help people and and I think that's
what Joe does you should check out his
Netflix specials he's he's brilliant go
see him live which was even better but
let's get into number five of the top 13
moments of 2019 you feel like you fit in
no I feel like I have like this
different mindset now I feel like with
my accomplishments I'm like yeah I
belong here man oh [ __ ] I walk into a
party I'm like yeah but you you did feel
like that before they all time or I was
like well what am I doing here
yeah but then I'm starting to get love
from other celebs and I'm just like okay
cool yeah people love you how many
people come up to you a day a lot a lot
yeah it's a lot it's kind of weird cuz
uh the Netflix is what put it over and
you're doing another one right I got two
more coming yeah two more come yeah but
you don't mic I didn't get that first
one man did I tell you my story I want
to hear it I didn't get it they passed
on me so when they made that big push
for stand-up comedy it was like 2016 and
they were they they announced at 2015
that they were gonna do like this huge
push for stand-up and they were gonna go
after all these comics and I was like I
want to get on that you know I didn't
want to go to Comedy Central again I
want to be on Netflix and uh and we kept
pursuing them kept inviting him to come
to the shows and you know I'm selling 18
shows in a row like come to one just see
what I'm doing like please give this to
me and they weren't coming and and then
finally they were like we're gonna pass
we already got everybody for 2016 and
you know we'll come out and look at you
onto that
17 for 2018 I'm like my son's gonna be
20 by then you know are you heartbroken
yeah was crushed cuz I didn't get it and
I'm not what did you think it was what
did you think it was I don't know I was
at politics I don't know what it was was
I not ready cuz I thought I was very
ready
the it was proven like I mean my demo
shows that it's it's relatable it's you
know I'm killing it and so I was really
like hurt you know I deserve this I've
won yeah and I and knowing that when you
have a son it's like you you know
especially in this business man like
especially comedy it's like how do you
show your son that I was appreciated or
something you know I mean like whenever
you say all my stand-up comic and 100
really where look tell me a joke or
they'll do something stupid like that if
they don't know you and this was that
that moment this was that what I needed
like this is what I wanted my son to be
like yeah that's my dad
you know like it was it was more than
just me it was like it was everything
you know is everything I've worked for
and I was just like I wanna I wanna when
I die I want my son to be like that's my
dad you know I mean so I could have done
the hate thing I could have went on
Twitter and just done that whole
deflecting the energy you know I mean
and absorbing just negativity and and
just bashing I could have done that
I really couldn't think about a lot of
people would have went to know I I mean
I was mad cuz I felt like I was like you
know I deserve this and I don't
understand why you know I said who
doesn't say that well he got one but I
didn't get one she got one I didn't get
one you could do that all day doesn't do
anything that doesn't do anything though
that no matter how many times people say
no to you you just I know you gotta dig
deep and show them you know and I
literally paid for that that special man
I paid every [ __ ] meme I need the
whole thing how much man I can't tell
you that because in the agreement when
they bought it from me you know they
things close you doubled it yeah you
know they gave me my money plus some
more let me just say was it over
$100,000 more that you played all your
own money way more way more hundreds of
thousands okay let me tell you why I
went way more because I could have went
that route we could have shot it for a
hundred thousand all right you know I
could have went to what any improv got
three cameras and shot it and I could
have said oh well them into the matter
is what's gonna sell it or I could make
it look like something that Netflix put
money into yeah like like this is
something that they would be proud of so
after that you edit this together yeah
put it together and your agent and you
guys send it back to Netflix the same
guys yeah we walked it in 3d you walked
it in well I didn't walk it in
they walked it in right cuz you said we
well I know well you know it is me and
my team for me and my team is me right
and that's my work you're a team player
yeah and so they hand us to them they
didn't watch it then they watch it on
their own they know they watched it in a
in a group all of the execs watched and
how soon after they bought it the minute
we dropped it it was like maybe a day
later or you know well this is what they
said we dropped it and they said don't
shop it around and the right when they
got it they watched it and then they
called my agent they go don't shop it
around we want to put in an offer so
just take it off the market and when he
told you that uh-huh I cried I was gonna
ask you did you cry on the phone
hell yeah I'm crying right now are you
that's a beautiful [ __ ] thing you
really are crying I know I [ __ ] love
that you're a real guy dude you're a
real [ __ ] that you still you have
that hard on you that just you know and
I knew it when I met you that that
inviting sort of you love people you
love life you love but you're passionate
about you do you're so passionate what
you do I love that you're crying oh you
made me cry like Rob cry you rob dude
that was my dream you know you wanted a
special yeah it's from delirious to that
like that's all I lived and you know
that's all I want to be was this
stand-up comic so them saying no I was
like what and I had to show him so a
[ __ ] story dude I don't know how many
people would do what you did like I said
this is gonna be a special year folks I
hope you stick around and tell your
friends force your friends to subscribe
in a non-threatening way remember the
video is coming back we're doing video
for inside of you it's going to be
coming hopefully soon
later stay tuned the police keep
listening also if you want to write into
the podcast remember hello at inside of
you podcast calm we love this stuff we
love reading stuff it touches me the the
letters I've gotten from you again your
support the patreon patrons joining
patreon and subscribing to the show and
giving back and getting extra
supplemental material and videos and all
that stuff really helps so thank you all
for that I really appreciate that number
four on the inside of you top 13 moments
of 2019 Wow this was a guest that just
said ah okay
she just opened up about her sexuality
she loved sex she had a lot of it her
relationship with para al pacino which
we're gonna listen to now a little bit
the crazy story about being boxed out by
Pacino's criminal business manager and a
beautiful moment between our dear friend
Carrie Fisher who passed away three
years ago this past Christmas it was
crazy man two weeks before she passed
away three years ago she had a party for
her 60th birthday at her house and I
brought her some cupcakes and some stuff
and then when she went off to film Star
Wars she I still had the message on my
machine maybe I'll play it for some time
but she said hey [ __ ] or something
hold on I'll be back in a couple of like
I'll be back next week let's all get
together and that was it and it wasn't
but like a week a week after that that
she passed and still in shock sometimes
I just sit there and go I had this
little room where it's just all my carry
stuff just like a picture of her chair
from force awakens and she gave me and
pictures and little things like that and
she always she I know you love this [ __ ]
take it she'll just she didn't care that
I was a Star Wars fan usually when
you're like friends with people that
you're kind of a fan of I don't know I
mean I'm sure it's a little weird but
you know it's not like I always looked
at her like here's Princess Leia it was
like I knew Carrie I know more about
Carrie
than a lot of people I know the moments
when she was married to Paul Simon I
know the letters that her and her ex
would write to each other I know so much
there was a real friendship she knows
about my family she knows she knew sorry
I feel like she's still here but hearing
this interview with Beverly D'Angelo who
was also way closer just a dear dear
friend of carries talking you could hear
Kerry's voice she plays a little video
but let's get into beverly d'angelo
number 4 on the top 13 moments of 2019
you know and you guys get along now yeah
now that took a while well it took a
while it took until I just went this guy
is never gonna change he's different
like this is when you mess up you in
love you were in love oh instantaneously
right yeah and you thought this is the
way it is and he says yeah I want you to
be the mother of my children that's in
three months and then seven years later
two kids later it was like not happening
was that heartbreaking for you I was
very much the rug was very much it was
it was very there was a lot of
internecine [ __ ] going on
he had a there was a parallel story he
had a business manager named Ken Starr
not the guy who did the right thing
right but after I had the kids I became
more involved and more privy to his his
financial scene because it was always
independent financially from the get-go
and but then having the I'd been on bed
rest for seven months the kids twins I
got pregnant when I was 40 owners there
was I was definitely not working I was
holding down the fort right so anyway
the kids were like six months old and
long story it was covered in Vanity Fair
so I'm not going to get into it I need
to read Vanity Fair but anyway in a
nutshell in a nutshell I said when the
kids were six months old I said your
business managers a crook and I said
five years from now it's gonna be you
and me and the kids are you and him
because
something screwy going on he'd done
something and little did I know that I
was igniting the fuse of a criminal and
that was in 2001 and he was also a
lawyer so al-5
I had finally got by the time the kids
were 2 I'd gotten al to agree to audit
him and you know we had kind of ramped
up to this audit that was supposed to
happen and right before I was gonna
leave for LA I was in the country house
and the estate manager called said what
are you doing I said I'm just online you
know he says the kids just leaving yeah
why it was like 6:30 and he said I just
wondered and then there's a knock at the
door because there were two houses
somebody saying knock at the door and
Bob state manager says I just want you
to know I'm quitting tomorrow I know it
okay and then the guy standing beside
him said are you beverly d'angelo and i
said yeah and he went you've been served
so I opened up this envelope and it's a
it's a custody filing and it's al signed
by the business manager because he's a
voice and it's a custody fight it was
odd and it said you know that al was
filing in court to get a grant to be
able to take the kids anywhere with him
without the mother I was worded even
what the [ __ ] that this come out I
called him up and said what is this
because well you know we're not married
so it's just you know a custody thing
because if you're not married you don't
know whatever and I was like huh know
what we'll do do I need a lawyer anyway
oh the court will give you one I went
the court so I'm like what the [ __ ] is
happening
the thing is I would go over to see
Carrie and just stay there
and we traveled all over the we we were
never out of touch but we had a lot of
serious hang time and one thing I did
learn how to do starting out early as
like a flower child floating around all
over the place and a musician was
hanging which is what I love yeah make
it up as you go along and if there's
music in it so inevitably whenever we
get together and it was something that
Griffin done actually said in in that
bright lights documentary about her I
really picked up on that when he said
that when they were roommates in New
York that they just sang all day long
I'm going into the kitchen it's exactly
how she would sound that's that's right
so anyway so that was a big part of our
life so the other day I don't know how I
found this but I was looking at my phone
and I found a video that that that in a
nutshell was really what our
relationship was our relationship was
agenda agenda lists when you think about
two women who were actresses and and
agenda list agenda unless and we just
hung out together and I really do think
that one of the ingredients of our
friendship was that what we wanted from
each other was friendship so it wasn't
like oh this Perry would have friends
that you know were as a result of work
or profession and they'd be their thing
and they'd be there for a while and then
they'd be gone when that mission was
accomplished but you know I was we
always had that thing anyway so I found
this this video that we made she'd just
gotten her dog Gary so I'm gonna play
the audio yeah and and and and for some
reason she just started singing too she
wanted me to film Gary we were making
they were taking pictures of Gary and
and she started singing come back to me
well let's hear it okay so this is on
your iPhone we're listening to this now
it's Beverly Angelo helate beautiful
Carrie Fisher
singing to Carrie's dog Gary yeah with a
song made up on the spot
Carrie Carrie over you get you see video
Getty again come back to me daddy orgy
booty booty come back to me can you see
me okay okay
[Applause]
that just honestly made no but I mean
that that's like that's it in a nutshell
and then I don't and then after that we
did it again and again and again you
know people who say you know what was
she like I was like it's to each person
she was different she had her own
relationships with everybody yeah you
know for me it was like I was kind of a
lost soul and she just and my bungalow
for a couple nights get your [ __ ]
together
and Sarah Paulson was getting her [ __ ]
together we're both kind of I always had
that she was help she was always hell
[Music]
number three I'll tell you Ryan
Sean Astin Sean Astin really opened up
talking about opening up about their
mothers Patty Duke very famous and he
really opened up about his mother's
mental health I can't believe how much
she opened up I thought for sure he was
gonna call me and say hey can you edit
that out and he didn't and that's what
helps people when we don't edit [ __ ] out
when people listen to go oh my god my
mom had you know bipolar disorder and my
mother had this and what I would I
really got what listen to this listen to
number three Sean Astin on the top 13
moments of 2019 well maybe well that my
mother was bipolar you better believe
like she like hit you yeah there's a
physical abuse really yeah usually
there's always a reason but there was
you know yeah but my dad was he would go
calm and it pissed her off because the
more she would freak out the more he
would just get mellow and mellow but
when he would when he would raise us
with stuff he'd say things like hey put
yourself in the other guys shoes and you
know two wrongs don't make a right and
he would say it at critical moments when
you just gotten beat up in school or
something like that and you'd you'd or
you you know you were opinionated about
stuff so there was a value system there
but to go back to the the the abuse
thing yeah we felt sorry for her you
know what I mean it was like watching a
little kid act out so even though we
were little kids and and a lot of times
I would kind of adopt the paternal vibe
you know that was an interesting role to
assume sometimes when she'd be freaking
out about my dad and in some ways she's
looking
to the kids for no defer to like to
adjudicate the fight you know your
father did this and your father did that
and he did this anyway and then she
looks at you and you're now in the
position of having to say like you're
right mom you know what he shouldn't
have done that
or be like well you know but you did
kind of flip out before you have it you
know work you're like this weird juror
so so what ends up happening is you
develop this ability to kind of you know
run between the raindrops where you
don't you're on yeah you know but you
all by the tone is what she really wants
she wants a nurturing support of
understanding tone you know and it's
impossible with any relationship to kind
of like break it all down and into its
component parts but this is the quality
that people are interested in hearing
because it's what's different from from
or it's what they've experienced that
people don't like to talk about so when
my mom was physically abusive I always
sensed that she knew what my limits were
and she didn't push past them so where
there was abuse you were kind of like it
was almost performance art and you kind
of like well maybe this doesn't hurt as
much as it could there was one or two
times where she lost it where she wasn't
I can see her eyes - you remember
exactly them oh yeah absolutely hundred
percent 100% I think she wanted to have
like the perfect kid she wanted to prove
to everyone that she was a like the
perfect mother and that you didn't have
to have the kind of turmoil that she had
in her life in order to have success so
when I was seven or eight I'm always
able to get the dates a little wrong or
the ages a little bit wrong but I was
seven or eight and she came to me and
said they're doing an after-school
special you remember these after school
nurses they would do these like issue of
the week shows child abuse teen
pregnancy drug addiction kind of
groundbreaking it was groundbreaking but
it was also lame because they would just
wrap it all up in a nice neat little
blow in 20 minutes you know but they
would still talk about it at least yeah
so they wanted my mom to play this
use of mother and she said okay but if
my son can be the abuse that's right
that's right so I played Jesus it was
called please don't hit me Mom and
please don't hit me man your mother as
your mother and you as you I actually
just saw the poster for it lanced guest
was in it I don't know if you ever knew
who lance guest was and Nancy McKeon of
what'd he call it a different facts of
life my brothers starting five years so
it was their three names my mom and
those two and then my name wasn't
mentioned on the poster at all but the
poster was of my mom crying on a couch
hugging me and I had like I should never
have there's like really big hair but it
was an interesting experience I mean
she's in the in the movie or in this
yeah she was a she was abusive so you
were like reliving your lot I mean your
life essentially you were playing the
part where it's like this is real what
this is actually happening in my house
but you didn't say that no one there I'm
sad when had no one in the world knew
anything that you think they just knew
you think people knew what that your mom
I think you could tell it was an amazing
learning experience not just the fight
scenes where she would be you know the
abuse scenes which I was a little bit
nervous uncomfortable laughter it's my
first acting story that I tell people is
that you know she's supposed to grab me
I like forgot to tell her something or I
dropped a math book or I don't know what
it was in this in the show and so she's
grabbing me in the kitchen and banging
me against the cupboard and so I'm
laughing and the directors getting
nervous you know these TV movies they
don't have a lot of time to sort of
think about stuff I was using because
it's interesting well interesting choice
Sean they were just panicked because I
wasn't doing what I'm supposed to do so
my mom took me outside and she goes Sean
this is my career I took a chance on you
right and I start to cry and she's like
okay yeah and they go and she's like
rolling rolling
so they roll and she's beating me up and
I'm crying and everything and then they
they say cut and the directors like god
that was amazing and my mom hugs me and
tears are rolling down my cheeks cuz
I've just like disappointed whatever and
she looks at me and she smiles you guys
honey that's that's acting you did it
like oh good okay
good that's like a good thing I guess
[Music]
number two this dude I you know I've
seen him at when I was doing comedy
doing stand-up boy was i frightened
stand-up was a really tough time for me
I had to pretend I was just fine and I
just watched the movie Judy oh yeah yeah
said Willer Zack Weller that's right I
listen to me this I'm gonna tell you
guys something I've never cried this
hard this long after seeing that movie
at the end 15 minutes of hard crying and
I don't regret it a bit it was cathartic
my dogs consoled me they really came to
me and they hugged me and kissed me well
they didn't hug me but they kissed me
she gets horrible stage fright Judy
Garland and I was like oh my god and she
died at 47 I'm like oh my god and she
all these things I was like she popped
pills that's what killed her I'm like oh
my god I'm just saying I felt like I can
relate I just did I felt like I was like
wow and she's 47 I'm like I'm 47 now and
I felt like it was that even that movie
was sort of a you have to have a wake-up
call or you will die people will die
you can't suffer you can't hurt your
body I've always had stage fright I
think that's the real thing and I never
wanted to admit it but I do
by the way I'm trying I think with
meditation and things I'm trying to calm
that it's not that big of a deal you
know do your [ __ ] don't think in the
future don't take a week stressing out
when you're wasting time stress out the
day of or the hour of give yourself a
chance maybe for an hour a day but doing
it to yourself fight-or-flight all the
time you know so going up with Dane Cook
against you know not against Dane Cook
but with these other huge talents he
stand-ups it was rough and Dane I was
surprisingly I thought is he going to
open up or see gonna be because
everybody has this perception it was
Dane Cook a dick was he this and he
[ __ ] talks to about things that make
you go yes this is a good dude this is a
solid guy he just texts me he wants to
come back on the podcast I love how open
he was about his brother's embezzlement
about life if you listen to the whole
podcast I talks about his dad there's
some sweet sweet moments number two of
the top 13 moments of 2019
Dane Cook greatest moments of my life
are sometimes the things that were the
absolute most atrocious because from
that you get tools you get tools that
you can then implement sometimes into
your work just sometimes into something
funny a funny story or are a performance
you know those things that like I lived
through that I studied the the steps the
empathy the the anger I allowed myself
to kind of sit in it I don't drink I
don't do drugs I've never done anything
in my life I feel feelings and then I
get to put that and share it in stories
in performance so there's nothing that
comes bad from weakness sometimes in
myself or in people around me that I
have to cohabitate with what's the when
you say attrocious and you probably
don't to talk about any of this but if
you do what's one thing you will talk
about that you're like you know this
happened in my life and as bad as it is
I learned so much from that and how did
you get through it well for me it was
putting my brother in jail I had to put
my blue basil man yeah so once that
happened and I don't I I pick and choose
where I talk about it because I it was a
cataclysmic betrayal in my life that
almost sent me into a and abyss of
depression so sometimes if and forgive
me if I say to you like I just don't
want to keep going down this rabbit hole
but to look at down from the cusp of it
for a minute yeah I can tell you that it
was like everything that I thought my
life was up until the day that that
happened and then the year to follow of
how bad it got it capsized me and it
made me a person that was very difficult
to be around because I was encumbered
and sad so I didn't I had to you know go
back over the years because I probably
didn't always treat people fairly
because I was mortified I was humiliated
by my brother publicly at a time when I
was hitting a level an extra line of
superstardom that I should
[ __ ] been enjoying 24/7 and I
couldn't there's like somebody's just
dragging you pulling you down when
you're trying to get up I I said a
couple times in previous interviews I
said I felt like I was surviving the
piranhas of Hollywood so well only to
find out my brother was the devil those
nuts would I change it now zero what I
change zero everything that I became
from that as a person and performer I
value myself even more from that
experience you know before we get into
the number one I also want to throw out
some just some love to everyone again
for making not making me do this but
showing me the light that I'm doing
something I really enjoy it I really
love doing this this podcast and right
in tell us how you feel write a review
get your friends to subscribe it's
important let's get into the number one
super talented
the best thing I think he said was my
work does not define me I am NOT my work
it just it really sat with me and let's
get into it
this is Rainn Wilson are you still
extremely hard on yourself even when
you're doing the office yeah did you
like going I have to step it up for a
hit show I have to be funny I have to be
this were you hard after the show yeah
you know I've I've gotten so much better
in the last four or five years like I've
really made big strides in a lot of ways
I used to be really career obsessed and
you know what that's like in in this
world of just constant comparing myself
to others and like why is he in that
movie and I'm not and and I was when I
was on the office like it was all about
like how do i leverage dwight to get
more movie roles and to get greater
stardom and and and so it was really
just hard on myself in the end really
kind of had OCD about about that you
know filming
that in my head and going over it over
it again and now I've really I really
let that go
how how well a lot of has been this
therapy work you know and you know just
work with my wife she's been really
supportive about it and well you know as
I have kind of loved myself more I think
going more into spirituality has allowed
me to love myself more so that I'm not I
am not my job I am not my success my
self-esteem is not it's certainly linked
to success and in my work but my I am
not my work I'm not how successful my
work is going so I don't need that
anymore but it used to be that way it
used to be that way and it kind of made
me an [ __ ] you know you were an
[ __ ] I wouldn't say I don't think if
you talked to the office cast they would
be like I don't rain was an [ __ ] I
think people we all get along and good
but I could be an [ __ ] yeah I could
be pretty narcissistic and self-centered
and yeah they had some I had some rough
years in there so there you have a guy's
top 13 moments it was really a joy
there's so many other great guests this
year we've got so many other great
guests coming on some will repeat
Stephen Amell he came back Morena
Baccarin
come on man that's exciting many other
guests I'm so excited
video is coming your way on YouTube so
make sure I'll let you know when that
comes out but we're gonna just try to
make the show better and better we're
not changing the show we added a little
intro a little outro a little more
talking about you guys and trying to be
more current you know we'd like to just
be a little more current and record the
intros and outros close to when we air
so we're trying different things and
it's hard with different schedules but
we love you we thank you this top 13
moments of 2019 for inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan thank you this
has been fantastic what uh what are your
Bryce I want to think Bryce cuz he he
really put a lot of this most of it
together he really did and Mia for
editing this really top-notch stuff and
you know we're just driving to be better
and better Ryan this has been great
thank you thank you yeah man this is a
lot of fun also the patreon I love ya
the patreon if you want to
patreon go to patreon subscribe to the
podcast you're gonna get a lot of stuff
I mean the top tier I think gets care
packages for me every four months I
think there's Q&A is with me
there's [ __ ] talking with Michael
Rosenbaum a bunch of other stuff too
extra podcast stuff extra extra extra so
I'm really excited about that and
remember Portland Oregon I will be there
at the end of January so come see
Smallville Knights come see Tom Welling
and I we got the wine
knocking point wines it's called pure
evil I'm the pure this time Wellings the
evil we sold out last year get the 10%
off it's in the intro I gave me all the
information alright this is a shout out
to the top tier patrons on patreon for
tax Cristina be Emily
mah Jason W Nancy D Nico P Sara V Trisha
Barry I and listen patrons patrons
I freakin love you guys I was so shocked
at like looking on they're going is
anyone gonna subscribe to this I don't
know everybody told me to do it also I'm
like boom 100 patrons right away and I'm
like this is awesome I'm like can I just
do inside of you for the rest of my life
also on social media don't forget to
follow and at inside of you pod on
Twitter at inside of you podcast on
Instagram and inside of your podcast on
Facebook also this is a message from a
fan brian says a message for Michael hey
Michael not sure if this will ever reach
you my name is Brian 30 years old from
Kansas City Missouri thank you for
staying true to yourself and doing
things that suit you
man I know small that was a long hours
and stressful but man it got me through
some difficult times in my life my
parents divorced grandparents death etc
I discovered your podcast and I came for
some humor but it has helped through so
much so many days dealing with panic and
anxiety and your podcast is a breath of
fresh air I have to make it out to the
west coast and meet at a convention or
something many blessings and that's
Brian Kelly so you see had what impact
you know the show has that means the
world to me thank you for for writing in
because I do read them you see I do read
these things
Oh
you